- So welcome everyone to
the second Shulman Lecture
in the Humanities for Metaphysics
Meets Cognitive Science.
Today I'm super-pleased to
welcome philosophy's rockstar
and that would be Professor David Chalmers
who is a university
Professor of Philosophy
and Neuroscience at NYU.
So Dave is a philosopher
but also did his PhD in
Philosophy and Cognitive Science
at Indiana University with Doug Hofstadter
and he also does a lot
of collaborative work
with neuroscientists and cognoscientists.
So he fits right in with our venue.
So I mean Dave is a
rockstar, partly just, well.
In all ways shall we say.
So his work is obviously that way.
He's known for, both I think
advancing really interesting,
speculative, controversial, new ideas
and also he has, one of the
things I love about his work
is he has an eye
for understanding deep
philosophical questions
and how to frame them,
both in distinctive new ways
and also in ways that kind of even,
like conventional philosophers
can grasp and understand
and engage with.
He's also looks like a
rockstar which I really love.
He's got the hair and
when I first met Dave,
he had even longer hair.
I was an impressionable, very
stressed out grad student
and in an American Philosophical
Association meeting,
Dave was in what was
called back in the day
The Smoker which is this horrible event
which I will go on with you later
but for all of us that
were graduate students,
we were all traumatized and Dave,
one of the outstanding things about him
is that he's incredibly welcoming
and supportive of new people in the field
and engages in really productive
conversations with them
and he did that for me
and it was probably the first time
I'd ever had that happen
and I felt so welcomed.
That's my primary memory of
Dave but that has continued.
I've known him for a long time
and he has always been that way with me,
with other philosophers kind of,
who are kind of getting
into the field and also in,
obviously with more senior people
and people who are kind of full-on engaged
with all of the major topics in the area.
So he's really a leader in all ways.
And I guess I will not
keep going on but I could.
Let's just welcome Dave.
He's gonna speak to us
about "The Meta-Problem of Consciousness".
Thank you.
- Well such a pleasure to
be here with old friends
and new talking in this series.
I'm gonna be talking about,
well as Lori mentioned
I went to my advisor
in graduate school in
philosophy and cognitive science
at Indiana University
about 30 years ago now,
was Douglas Hofstadter.
I don't know how many of you
have read Hofstadter's works
like "Godel, Escher, Bach" and so on
but he was particularly
fond of the meta perspective
to almost any problem.
I mean there's this slogan
which is sometimes attributed to him.
"Anything you can do, I can do meta."
He denies that it was him
and there's actually a long trail
of interesting history
for that very slogan
that I won't go into.
If you go online actually,
you can find a meme attributing
this to Immanuel Kant
which is not especially plausible.
But yeah, so the idea today is
that thinking about making progress
on the problem of consciousness.
Maybe one form of progress
can be achieved by going meta.
By jumping out of the
system, going up a level
and that's gonna be what I'm going to
try to explore in what follows.
Okay, so when I was.
Actually in graduate
school I went to a talk
where they told me that meta
X always means X about X.
So metacognition,
cognition about cognition.
A metatheory, it's a
theory about the theory.
Okay, of course we immediately set about
finding counter examples and metaphysics.
Is that physics about physics?
No, not really.
Meta ethics, is that ethics about ethics?
But this one actually fits the template.
The meta-problem of
consciousness is so-called
because it's a problem about a problem.
And the meta-problem of
consciousness as I understand it
is to explain why we think and say
that there's a problem of consciousness
and my thought is that
that's a distinctive approach
to the problem of consciousness
that might itself be
productive and interesting.
I've been told I need to
go exactly 45 minutes,
so let me make sure I've got
my timer in hand, very good.
Lori is fully authorized
to cut me off at 45 minutes
and zero seconds.
I need that stopwatch
with a second hand now.
Okay, so the meta problem is
a problem about a problem.
That presupposes first order
problem about consciousness
and in this context,
that problem is the so-called
hard problem of consciousness.
I think we said I was going
to take my mask off right?
If that's, I gather the convention
is for speakers to remove the mask
and audience to keep it on.
If anybody is uncomfortable
and prefer I put it back on,
just let me know.
The hard problem of consciousness
is the problem of explaining why and how
physical processes give rise
to conscious experience.
Here, okay so here's an illustration
of the hard problem which I quite like
because it somehow
illustrates consciousness
as someone's hair catching fire.
This is maybe some kind of illustration
of the magic of conscious experience
but the hard problem is
concerned with what philosophers
often call phenomenal consciousness
which is basically tied to
what it's like to be a subject.
So you know, this locution goes back
at least to a famous paper by
my NYU colleague Tom Nagel.
In 1974 he wrote, "What
is it like to be a bat?"
And the thought was although we don't know
what it's like to be a bat.
So engaging in sonar,
is it more like vision,
is it more like hearing?
But presumably there's
something it's like to be a bat.
A bat has subjective experience.
Just as there's something
it's like to be me,
there's something it's like to be you.
We assume something it's like to be a bat,
most people would say
nothing it's like to be say,
a cup or a water bottle.
There's something it's
like to be a system,
you know roughly when it has
some kind of subjective experience.
So we say a system is
phenomenally conscious
if there's something it's like to be it.
A mental state is phenomenally conscious
if there's something it's
like to be in that state.
So states of phenomenal
consciousness include
visual experiences like the
experience of color and depth.
There's something it's like
to have those experiences.
Other sensory experiences
like of sound or taste.
Bodily sensations like pain or orgasm.
Mental imagery like recalled visual images
from your childhood.
Emotional experiences
like happiness or anger
or indeed a stream of a current thought
like reflection and decision.
All sometimes thought of as elements
of this rich inner movie of consciousness.
States that feel like
something to the subject.
The hard, the locution the hard problem
is meant to contrast with other problems
of consciousness and of
cognition more generally.
The so-called easy problems
which aren't easy in any absolute sense.
They're as hard as any problem in science
but they're called the easy problem
because we've got some,
at least, better grip
on how to go about explaining them.
These are basically problems
of explaining behavioral
or cognitive functions like
say perceptual discrimination,
the integration of
information in the brain,
the control of behavior
and indeed verbal reports like saying,
"I see that object now."
These are all relatively
objective features
of the human system.
We have a fairly standard
paradigm for explaining them
in cognitive science.
Roughly we handle the easy problems,
these problems of explaining behavioral
or cognitive functions by finding a neural
or a computational mechanism
that performs the relevant function.
Maybe a neural system,
maybe some kind of algorithmic mechanism
but once you've explained how it is
that that function is performed,
you've explained the problem.
But for the hard problem of
consciousness distinctively,
it looks like explaining
all those objective
behavioral cognitive functions
seems to always leave
open a further question.
Why is all that accompanied by experience?
Why is this something it's like
to undergo those processes?
You know why doesn't all that
processing go on in the dark,
without consciousness as it might in say,
I don't know, a robot or a zombie?
There seems to be what philosophers call
an explanatory gap here
between physical processes
and subjective experience.
So that's the hard problem.
Here's an illustration
of something very strange happening
in the vicinity of the
brain and consciousness
that we're trying to get to the bottom of
in solving the hard problem.
And there are many different
approaches to the hard problem.
In both,
coming both from the side of
metaphysics and philosophy
or from the side of the
science of consciousness.
I mean there are approaches that take
consciousness to be irreducible in nature
and this is actually the side
which I have somewhat more sympathy for
and I've argued myself
in some earlier work,
that consciousness could be
fundamental and irreducible
in the same way that
space and time and mass
are often taken to be.
This leads you to views like dualism,
consciousness is distinct
from any physical properties
but is somehow in interaction with them.
Or a panpsychism, that there's
some element of consciousness
at the base of all physical systems.
Or even idealism,
that the whole world is itself
a construct of consciousness.
Okay so that's one set of options.
Another set of options is that
consciousness is reducible.
Perhaps to some kind of
computational or functional process
as popular functionalist views hold.
Perhaps to something really
distinctively biological,
that's biological materialism.
Some people have even speculated
maybe there's something
essentially quantum mechanical
about consciousness
and we can reduce it to some
kind of quantum materialism
and there's been a big debate about these,
about these options here.
In both the metaphysics and
the science of consciousness
but here I'm not gonna be
concerned with either of those.
Instead I'm gonna be
taking a third approach.
The third approach is to do what yeah,
what Douglas Hofstadter called
jumping out of the system
and going meta.
So instead of trying to solve
the problem we ask instead,
"Why is it that we think
"that consciousness poses a problem?"
And when you ask the question in this way,
I think it just gives you
just a different angle
on the problem
that comes with all kinds
of promising new directions.
One way to get at this
is to look at various behavioral functions
that are closely related
to the hard problem.
The hard problem's about
experience, not about behavior
but there are behavioral functions
that are very closely connected.
Not least that we make what I'll call,
phenomenal reports or reports
of conscious experience.
Oh dear, I hope that's not ominous.
Ah yeah, perfect.
Okay so yeah these objective function
which is closely related to consciousness
is the existence of phenomenal reports
or verbal reports of
conscious experiences.
People say things like,
"I am conscious, there's
something it's like to be me.
"I am feeling pain now and so on."
And although consciousness
itself may be a hard problem,
looks like these reports
are in the vicinity
of objective functions,
potentially explicable by
the standard mechanisms
of cognitive science.
So in principle, explaining
those falls under the category
of the easy problem.
Oh sorry, next one.
Then we also have what
I call problem reports
which are you know,
reports that consciousness
seems like peculiarly mysterious
or difficult to explain.
Sorry, can we go back one?
To the one that says problem reports.
Perfect.
Reports expressing our sense
that consciousness poses a hard problem.
Maybe it's a slightly smaller group now
but there are at least
some people out there
who say things like,
"Boy it's really
disturbing seeing yourself
"like that from the side."
But yeah, right yeah.
Super meta, self consciousness
upon self consciousness
and who is that zombie David
Chalmers who's underneath?
That's really worrying.
There is a hard problem of consciousness,
people say things like explaining behavior
doesn't explain consciousness.
Oh fantastic, thanks.
Sorry about that.
Consciousness seems
nonphysical and so on again.
Those things are behaviors,
in principle open to paradigmatic,
cognitive science explanation.
So the meta problem of
consciousness as I understand it
is basically the problem of explaining
those problem reports.
In principle, puzzle about behavior.
So it's an easy problem
or to be open to standard kinds
of functional explanation.
So the meta problem is an easy problem
but it's closely tied to the hard problem.
In some ways it looks more tractable
than the hard problem
and solving ought to at
least shed some light
on the hard problem.
If you like, this is
a kind of potentially,
what people call a genealogical approach
to philosophical problems.
We don't exactly try and
solve the problem directly
but we look at why it is
that this problem exists
in the first place.
Sometimes people do this
by focusing on cultural,
on cultural history
or maybe some kind of
evolutionary history.
For example, you know, you might take,
some people take this approach to God.
Instead of trying to
figure out is there a God,
figure out why do we think there's a God
in the first place.
Sometimes if you find some evolutionary
or cultural explanation of
why we think there's a God,
some people then think
okay, that actually debunks
the existence of God.
We no longer have strong
reason to believe in God
after we have explained
why we have these beliefs.
That much is controversial
but it's quite common to take this line
about consciousness at
least in recent years.
A few people have taken it
and this leads to the view
sometimes called illusionism.
That consciousness or at least
the problem of consciousness
is an illusion.
We believe that there are these special,
we have these special
properties that pose a problem
but we don't really explain
why we have those beliefs
and we might dissolve the problem.
So that's to say that
solving the meta problem
could dissolve the hard problem.
And in recent years that's actually become
quite a popular view.
This started to receive
some systematic attention.
Here's a book that
focused on a central paper
by Keith Frankish called
"Illusionism: As the
Theory of Consciousness".
Yeah, depicting the mind-body problem
as some kind of magic trick.
We all seem to ourselves
to have these magical properties
that in fact, we don't.
In fact illusionism has a
long history in philosophy.
So Immanuel Kant in the
Critique of Pure Reason
talked about some elements
of the unity of self
as a transcendental illusion.
The materialist philosopher U. T. Place
who identified mental states
for the brain states said,
"Yeah we have this sense
there's something more."
But he said it was a kind
of phenomenological fallacy.
Another Australian
philosopher, David Armstrong
talked about a distinctive
kind of illusion
tied to a circus illusion
called the headless woman illusion.
I'll get to that shortly.
More recently Dan Dennett has talked about
a consciousness as a user illusion.
Keith Frankish I mentioned already.
Michael Graziano, the psychologist
had something he calls the
attention schema theory.
That we have all these schemas
for thinking about the mind.
Self models that drive us astray.
So it's a, it's a popular
and important view.
I don't think though,
so many illusionists.
Illusionists have a special motivation
to be interested in the
meta problem but I think,
I'm not myself an illusionist.
I think the meta problem is
interesting even independently
of being an illusionist.
I'm what philosophers call a
realist about consciousness.
In philosophy, to a first approximation,
to be a realist about something
is roughly to believe it's real.
So a moral realist is someone
who thinks morality is real.
A realist about consciousness
thinks consciousness is real.
I think consciousness is not an illusion.
I think that solving,
I don't think that
solving the meta problem
suddenly dissolves the hard problem.
But nonetheless,
I think the meta problem is
interesting in its own right.
I think it's tractable and that solving it
has the potential to at the very least,
shed much light on the hard problem,
even if it doesn't constitute
a solution in its own right.
When I think there's actually a,
there's actually a research program here.
What I'll call the
meta-problem research program
which I think is a potentially
very productive one.
It's open to realists
and illusionists alike
to try and solve the meta-problem.
Try and explain these problem reports.
It's open to reductionists
and non-reductionists,
illusionists and non-illusionists.
We can try and solve the meta problem
and then think about the
philosophical consequences.
One reason why I think this
meta-problem program is cool
is it comes with a fairly clear program
in both philosophy and cognitive science.
Remember the problem was basically,
really we might put this as to explain
certain intuitions we have.
It's really to explain certain reports
but maybe some underlying intuitions
or maybe to explain why
it's possible to explain
these intuitions.
But yeah, this actually brings in
I think a number of different areas
of cognitive science really at the core.
It's a problem, the
problem of consciousness.
You might think it comes from
a philosophical background
as the mind-body problem.
A problem in metaphysics, what
is the nature of the mind?
The nature of consciousness.
But by focusing on the meta-problem,
this at least carves
off a bit of the problem
that comes with a tractable
program in cognitive science.
So one thing we want to do I think first
is to distinguish a bunch
of different problem reports
or problem intuitions
that people often display
that lead people to think there's a,
there's a, that are associated
with there being a
problem of consciousness
and I divide these into
at least four groups.
There are metaphysical intuitions,
intuitions to the effect
that consciousness seems
somehow to be non-physical.
There are explanatory intuitions
tied to this core idea that consciousness
is hard to explain,
explaining these objective functions
doesn't explain consciousness.
There are knowledge intuitions.
Here the paradigmatic one would be
Frank Jackson's classic case of Mary
the scientist who was brought
up in a black and white room,
knows all the physical
facts about color processing
in the brain and
wavelengths and associations
but it seems she doesn't know
one really important thing,
she doesn't know what
it's like to see red.
One day she sees a red
rose for the first time
and she learns something new.
So that's the knowledge intuition.
Then there are, yeah
there are modal intuitions
tied to what we can imagine or conceive.
What seems possible.
So you know, various
philosophers including me
have argued we can at
least conceive of zombies,
systems functionally
perhaps physically like us
but without consciousness.
So these are some of the
core intuitions in the,
associated with the
problem of consciousness.
There are some others too.
Maybe slightly less close to the core.
There are intuitions about
the distribution of consciousness.
Maybe that robots are not conscious
or that groups are not
conscious for example.
Intuitions about the
value of consciousness,
that consciousness matters morally.
Actually yesterday I was giving a talk
which turned in central part
on that kind of intuition.
Intuitions about the self,
that the self persists through time.
Intuitions about the qualities
presented in consciousness.
That special quality,
like the redness of red
is somehow directly available to me.
But I'll concentrate
especially on the first four.
Now I think one of the
cool things about this
meta-problem project is it comes with
a very natural interdisciplinary
research program.
All kinds of work is
potentially relevant here.
There's experimental work in
both experimental psychology
and in let's call it these days,
experimental philosophy
where you empirically study
people's intuitions about these things.
Here, particularly studying
people's intuitions
about consciousness and
the associated problems.
There's also building of
models, computational models,
neurobiological models
of intuitions and reports
and there's also a whole lot of room
for philosophical analysis.
So I think this meta-problem program
is just ripe for
interdisciplinary exploration
and it's been getting a bit
of that in recent years.
I mean for starters,
I mean it's an empirical question
how widely these intuitions are shared.
In a paper I wrote on this maybe,
four years or so ago now I argued
they were gonna be very widely shared
and you'd expect them
to be and not universal.
Some people argued with that
and there actually begun to be
some empirical studies of this.
My own sense is that,
yeah and these intuitions,
one might expect
to be quite widely shared.
Especially if one's a
realist about consciousness,
you might think well the
source of these intuitions
is gotta be deeply tied to
actually being conscious.
Presumably being conscious is
something that's universal,
at least if one's a realist.
So at least that source of the intuitions
should be widely shared.
Maybe it doesn't actually lead
to these intuitions in
everybody but you might think,
okay, at the very least a
tendency in that direction
ought to be widely shared.
A disposition to say these things.
Even if it's sometimes
overridden by other things in a,
in any given system.
I mean the alternative view though
is that they're somehow
cultural and local.
Maybe Descartes, Rene
Descartes gets blamed
for a lot of stuff in philosophy
and cognitive science.
Maybe these mind-body intuitions
are all Descartes' fault.
I find that very deeply implausible myself
but then maybe I would,
given that I have these
intuitions very strongly
but I do think this is
an empirical question.
You know traditionally I think,
and you know the last couple of decades
of cognitive science,
there's been a fair
amount of empirical work
on intuitions about the
mind but that were concerns,
especially I think belief
like under what conditions
infants have the concept
of a false belief.
Intuitions about the self.
Like how, how selves persist over time.
Whether they might continue
after death and so on.
Where consciousness is concerned,
perhaps the biggest body of work
has been on distribution
of consciousness in robots
and groups and so on.
Josh Knobe has done some
well-known work about,
on those questions.
Where, where problem
intuitions are concerned.
At least, when I wrote this,
when I first started writing about this
four or five years ago
there wasn't so much.
Now there's come to be,
there's come to at least
be a small literature
experimentally studying these intuitions.
In something I wrote I said the one,
the intuition I would
expect to be most robust
and widespread is the intuition about Mary
in the black and white room.
Not knowing what it's like to see red
and then learning something.
Just recently, Daniel Gregory
and a couple of other philosophers
have published a very nice
experimental study of this
called "Who knows what Mary knew?"
And they find that,
they asked the question.
Did Mary know what it's like to see red?
When she had that complete
physical knowledge
but had not yet actually
experienced the color,
did Mary know what it's like to see red?
82% said no she didn't
but then upon seeing
it for the first time,
did she then know what
it's like to see red?
90% said yes.
So okay that's fairly robust.
I mean no one expects to get
100% on any of these things
but 80 to 90% indicates
some pretty serious effect.
There are also explanatory intuitions.
There's a nice paper by Sara
Gottlieb and Tania Lombrozo.
It doesn't focus just on consciousness
but focuses on questions
about under what conditions
do people have the intuition
that certain mental phenomena
are hard to explain
scientifically and they find
people seem to think that mental phenomena
are especially hard to explain
when they're tied to subjective experience
and privileged awareness.
Which at least goes
along with the idea that
some distinctive explanatory intuitions
tied to the hard problem.
Tied to the hardness of the
hard problem for consciousness.
More recently there's an
article by Rodrigo Diaz
called "Do people think
consciousness poses a hard problem"
where he's actually trying to
argue that these intuitions
are not so widespread
and actually there's a lot
to say about this paper
which is very interesting.
It turns out a whole lot depends on things
like your preamble and your
setting up of the problem.
If you've set it up
with super pro-science,
neurobiology ra ra,
then people say okay yeah
science is doing great.
If you set it up with a lot of stuff
about how consciousness is
so mysterious, not so good.
But with a reasonably neutral setup,
I think he gets about 50% of people saying
consciousness is hard to explain.
50% not.
So interesting to know
what to make of this.
So much to, I mean it's
hard to experimentally test
a lot of these things
because we have to use words
like explanation which is so
ambiguous and conceivability
which has got technical
meanings and so on.
So tricky but at least we're,
I think the literature
here at least is beginning
to develop.
Actually I've done
a tiny bit of empirical
work about this myself.
I'm not exactly an
experimental philosopher
but every now and then I've
taken empirical surveys
of intuitions about philosophy.
Restricted to the class of
professional philosophers.
So David Bourget and I are independently,
we co-developed a website, PhilPapers
which is basically a giant
bibliography of philosophy.
Two million entries and
it's basically turned into
a giant database of
philosophy of all kinds
and well along the way
this involved building
a giant database of email
addresses of all philosophers.
So we found ourselves back in 2009
in a position to contact
I think philosophers
in 100 departments of
philosophy around the world
and to ask them for their views
on 30 key philosophical
problems like materialism.
Yes, no, other with various other options.
We did it again in 2020,
this time with 100 questions
and many more philosophers
and I think we asked 8000
and got 2000 responses
and one of the questions this time was,
"Is there a hard problem
of consciousness?"
And we found 62% of philosophers say yes.
30% say no.
Okay this is a rather
selected and corrupted group
that maybe doesn't reveal a whole lot
about pre-theoretical intuitions
because philosophers have
thought about this a lot.
Still interesting data.
There was, among scientists,
I don't know of an exact
equivalent of the PhilPapers survey
for surveying psychologists,
neuroscientists,
AI researchers in general but I do know,
there was one survey
back in 2018 of attendees
at the Association for the
Scientific Study of Consciousness
where it's majority
neuroscientists and psychologists
with again 60% saying some
kind of explanatory gap
on explaining functional
behavioral properties of things.
There's a gap to consciousness.
Again this group is selected
for being interested in consciousness.
So by no means a pure sample
of pre-theoretical intuitions
but interesting data all the same.
There's obviously room
for a lot more experimental work there
so I'm really trying to encourage
this kind of experimental
philosophy and psychology
of intuitions about consciousness.
So I want to say a bit
about potential solutions
to the problems.
Because you know this idea
of explaining our intuitions
has been around for awhile
but there are at least some
kind of quasi-standard approaches here.
I mean this literature
is extremely fragmented.
I think at least until recently
there was just a proposal
here and a proposal there
that didn't really make
contact with each other
but I think it's possible
to systematize them
and I've tried to do this a little bit
by looking at a few different factors
that might be generating
these intuitions about
consciousness and again,
these moves are available
equally to the illusionist
who thinks it's all an illusion
and the realist who
thinks all this is real.
One key very basic idea.
Doug Hofstadter I think has argued
for this kind of view at some
length and more recently,
Michael Graziano's theory
is a version of this.
Basically says that it all comes down
to certain internal self models.
We all have models of ourselves.
In particular,
models of our own cognitive processes.
And these models can greatly
distort the real thing.
Sometimes they greatly
simplify the real thing.
Sometimes they add to the real thing.
They didn't exactly resemble,
the didn't represent
the real thing perfectly
but these introspective
models will somehow explain
our sense that we're conscious
and that there's a
problem of consciousness
and that much I find quite plausible
but now the question is how.
What kind of introspective
models are going to do this?
Well here's a Escher
print that Hofstader uses
that somehow explain the idea that
our wonky, self models
somehow lead to the existence
of the problem represented
by the big hole at the center
where nothing makes sense.
A related idea is this idea
often associated with David Armstrong.
Of introspective opacity
and here the key idea is,
well we don't see that
consciousness is physical.
Introspection is opaque
as to the underlying mechanisms.
It doesn't show us
the underlying mechanisms
of consciousness.
We don't see the consciousness as physical
and then we go on to infer,
we go on to see it as non-physical
and this is meant to have
some analogs with this.
This circus illusion
of the headless person.
We don't see their head.
So we see them as having no head.
Here's a picture the so-called
headless woman illusion
which was I guess popular
in 19th century circuses
and there's just, you know
there's someone sitting there
with her head behind a screen
and I guess the idea is that
under the right conditions,
at least for a moment you
look at this and it's like,
"Oh my God, that person has no head."
I don't know how much
the perceptual system
really gets taken in by this
but maybe there were circumstances
where it looks a little bit like that.
I certainly, I mean I do think
it takes special circumstances
to get this going.
I mean I can block out
the heads of a few of you
and it doesn't suddenly look like
there's a bunch of headless
people in the audience.
So I think there's,
you only actually make this inference
under certain very special,
under certain very special conditions.
So I think that itself needs explaining.
There's also further
questions like you know,
why doesn't introspection of say belief
and other mental states
generate the same gap.
Indeed, even for our awareness of say,
of computers and algorithms.
I know my iPhone is running some kind of,
some kind of computation under
the surface when I use this
but I've got no idea.
I mean for most of us, it's totally,
who knows what's going on in there.
I guess it's some kind of silicon circuits
but you know we've got
no awareness of that.
We've got no awareness
of the physical processes
underneath, underneath all this
but it doesn't mean that
we suddenly have some sense
that it's non-physical.
So I think this
explanation overgeneralizes
even though there may be something to it.
One idea is that color experience
and other kind of
experiences may attribute
certain kinds of primitive
qualities to objects.
So there's red, that
red exit sign and so on.
What's actually going on in nature
is some very complex
reflectance property up there
but we model it as this very simple,
primitive feature of you
know, redness in the world.
It's a primitive quality
instantiated out there in the world
and that makes maybe for
some very simple model
of things in the world,
is having these different
primitive colors.
Likewise for yellow and the like.
In some other work I have thought of this
as modeling the external world
asa kind of a garden of Eden
with all these primitive qualities
exactly as they appear
in, to us in perception.
That identic world could at least serve
as a useful model of the
complex, non-identic world
that we live in.
So maybe, then the thought is
maybe something like that's
going on in the mind.
Maybe to model the mind,
we also attribute primitive
qualities to the mind,
the same way we attribute
primitive qualities to the world.
I'm not sure that gets
at the key issue though
which is tied to our experience
or our awareness of qualities
and I think to get to that,
you really need to go beyond this,
to well a sense of being
related to these qualities
in the world and being aware of them.
And maybe in particular
our internal models
give us a sense of being acquainted.
Both with concrete qualities
and with our awareness
of them which I think is,
I think this is, they say I think
is getting closer to
the heart of the matter.
But as with all these explanations,
it always just keeps pushing
back the question a bit for me.
Okay but how and why does that work?
So if I were to kind of
put all this together
into a summary,
here's my summary of one possible approach
of potential beginning
of a solution sketch
to the meta-problem.
Why do we make, why do we have this sense
there's a problem of consciousness?
One thing I like by the way
about this kind of summary
is you could either realize this,
read this in a realist
tone of voice about,
from the point of view
of someone who thinks
consciousness is real and
these are the mechanisms
or in an illusionist tone of voice
where this is an account of the illusion.
I think the kind of
explanation I'm giving here
is neutral in that.
You just say okay we
have introspective models
deploying introspective
concepts of our internal states
that are largely independent
of our physical concepts.
These concepts are introspectively opaque,
not revealing any of the
underlying mechanisms,
our perceptual models,
perceptually attribute
primitive perceptual
qualities to the world
and our introspective models
attribute primitive mental
relations to these qualities.
These models produce the
sense of acquaintance
both with those qualities
and with our awareness
of those qualities.
I'm inclined to find something like this
somewhat plausible as an account of
what's going into the intuitions.
At the same time it feels to be more like,
less like an explanation of the intuitions
and more like a kind of fleshing out
of what the intuitions are.
What I'd really like to
see is some kind of story
of maybe some kind of algorithmic
basis for the intuitions.
Where things went this way and where,
if you actually built that algorithm
you would see it displaying
the relevant intuitions.
I mean one way we can test solutions
to the meta problem is by
trying to formulate them,
maybe in some kind of algorithmic terms,
test those explanations
with psychological studies
and computational models.
I mean the only thing in this direction
I really know so far is
something by Luke Muehlhauser
and Back Schlergeras
where they took some fairly simple ideas
about the meta problem,
that the philosopher Francois
Kammerer and I had put forward
and they tried to build in those ideas
into a little software agent
which they gave a bunch of axioms
and the ability to derive conclusions
from those axioms and
a few basic principles
about consciousness as the axioms.
And they actually found it produced
little theorems, little reports like,
"Yeah consciousness, my experience of red
"distinct from any brain
process and so on."
Okay which is promising and interesting
although I think they,
it's very much a toy model
and they do build quite
a lot into this model.
Interesting question,
if a machine issues the same
sort of problem reports as us,
and caused by similar mechanisms
that we think are present in us,
should we take that actually as evidence
that the machine is conscious?
Here a few people have suggested
that you could actually
potentially use problem reports
as a sort of Turing test
for machine consciousness.
Aaron Sloman, Susan
Schneider, Ed Turner have said
you know one way to test
whether a machine is conscious
is to see whether it is
possible to mount consciousness.
If it says you know,
"Well I know I'm just a
bunch of silicon chips
"but I feel subjectively
like so much more."
Then is that some kind of sign
that it might actually be conscious?
On the other hand you might say,
the machine say, well Dan
why do I need to go through?
Why do I need to be so
theoretically confused
as those damn humans.
It's like in the regular
Turing test the poor machine
has to drag itself down to
talk like a dumb human being.
Here's the poor sad machine studying
the talk like a human test
book, test preparation book.
Likewise for the meta problem,
it's like okay why do
I really need to have
confused intuitions about consciousness
as the humans did do?
But if it did display
those intuitions though,
maybe that would be some evidence.
I was gonna say something
about impact on theories of consciousness
although maybe I think I'll skip over this
for reasons of time.
Here the idea is from
a realist perspective,
a solution to the meta-problem
and a solution to the hard problem
might be closely connected
and we could use this as a
kind of test for theories
of consciousness.
See whatever explains consciousness
should also partly explain
our judgements about consciousness.
And here the idea is it would be strange
if the basis of consciousness
played no role at all
in judgments about consciousness.
And here I go on to argue
that some theories of consciousness
don't seem to pass this test.
That the mechanisms of
consciousness explain the judgments
about consciousness.
I mean I argue for example
that Tononi's integrated
information theory has trouble
meeting this, meeting this challenge
but maybe I'll skip over
that for reasons of time.
So just to conclude I'll,
and just by saying
something a little bit about
this underlying issue between the realist
and the illusionist about consciousness.
Some of the illusionist says
consciousness doesn't exist,
we just think it does.
A solution to the meta-problem
dissolves the hard problem.
Strong illusionism says
phenomenal consciousness
does not exist at all.
You know this is a very
attractively austere view
of consciousness.
Its main problem is it seems
somehow impossible to believe.
Here's one way to put the
argument against it as a,
just a flat footed argument.
It's like people sometimes feel pain.
If strong illusionism is
true, no one feels pain.
Therefore strong illusionism is false.
Well here the underlying idea is,
well it's just a datam
that we have certain kinds
of conscious experiences
like feeling pain, experiencing red.
You might put this in some
neutral form, it's like,
well it's unbelievable,
it's just impossible
to believe illusionism
because it's somehow unbelievable
that no one feels pain
and that no one is conscious.
So illusionism is unbelievable.
Now the illusionist does themselves
have an interesting reply here which is,
my view predicts that
my view is unbelievable.
You know it's just those models
you have in your brain that forces you
to think you're conscious
and that consciousness
can't be an illusion but
it might still be wrong.
So just to conclude then,
when we're putting this
kind of illusionist,
realist showdown as
between two different forms
of absurdity.
Two different kinds of
claims about absurdity.
Here's the philosopher Galen Strawson
saying illusionism is absurd.
"There occurred in the 20th century
"the most remarkable episode
in the whole history of ideas.
"A number of thinkers denied the existence
"of something we know
with certainty to exist,
"namely consciousness."
Okay so it's the most absurd
thing he's ever heard.
Here on the other side is
the rationalist philosopher,
Eliezer Yudkowsky.
Arguing that epiphenomenalism
is absurd and here he was,
this was something he wrote
engaging with some of my ideas
in my book "The Conscious Mind"
where I talked about zombies.
He said, "The Zombie
Argument may be a candidate
"for the most deranged
idea in all of philosophy.
"The causally closed cognitive system
"of Chalmers' internal narrative
"is malfunctioning in a
way that not by necessity,
"but just in our universe,
"miraculously happens to be correct."
And here, this is getting
at an interesting idea
which is if you're a
realist about consciousness,
maybe not just an epiphenomenalist
but a realist more generally,
somehow it looks like
you can explain all those things we say
without mentioning consciousness.
So something the fact
that the things we say
are actually true ends up being
kind of a remarkable coincidence.
So realism ends up being absurd too.
There is middle ground here of course
between those extreme views.
I think it tends to slide
back to the same problems.
Other forms of illusionism don't
help with the hard problem.
Other forms of realism are still subject
to the miraculous correctness
or the idea that really
true by coincidence.
So why I think to get
beyond absurdity here,
I think there's challenges for both sides.
The illusionist needs to explain
how having a mind can be somehow like this
even if it's not the way,
if it's not completely
the way that it seems.
The realist needs to explain,
to avoid this coincidence worry
the realist needs to explain
how meta-problem processes
are essentially grounded in consciousness
even if it's possible
for them to occur without consciousness.
But either way I think.
I mean if we can get a
solution to the meta-problem
that meets these ambitions,
that may just possibly lead to a solution
to the hard problem of consciousness.
In the meantime I think the meta-problem
is a potentially
tractable research project
for everyone, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Lori] Two minutes to spare.
- Two to spare, very good.
- Well done.
Well now is the time for Q and A.
Moderated by Professor Shull.
- We have 10 to 15 minutes
for questions for Professor Chalmers,
after which he will be visiting
the metaphysics meets
cognitive science course.
Who has some questions
about consciousness?
Who has some meta questions?
- I.
- Anyone, anyone?
Sure.
- I'll start things off
if I can.
So in, oh yes thank you.
In your slide where you
kind of summarize the view
that you were developing.
I actually just had a question
about the interpretation
of that text and so I wanted
to ask you about that.
Thanks for going back to that.
Yes, so you say our perceptual models
perceptually attribute
primitive perceptual qualities
to the world.
And I just didn't understand that phrase,
this is legitimate.
And just if you could
say a little bit more
about what you mean by
perceptual attribution
and primitive perceptual
qualities and then I actually then
had a secondary question which is,
I don't really know what you mean
by the sense of acquaintance.
So I'm just wondering
if you could elaborate
on that a little bit.
- Okay so the perceptual models
and the primitive perceptual qualities
was meant to be a version
of you know, this thing.
The, like the intuition's
ground learning color experience
that somehow yeah,
in perception it's like
redness just seems to be this,
kind of this primitive quality of objects.
That redness is kind of
spread out over the exit sign.
It seems to be this very distinctive,
shiny quality out there.
As far as perception is concerned,
it seems to be basically
a primitive thing.
There's red and there's and there's green
and maybe there's amounts of,
there's amounts of redness
and amounts of blueness
that we can decompose phenomenologically
but it certainly doesn't
seem to be a complex property
or a reducible property.
So many people have made this point
about the phenomenology of color.
That in seeing a color, we seem to be,
the world seems to be populated
by these special primitive qualities
and I think something
similar might go for a pitch,
you can argue about space.
But at least for a color,
are you uncomfortable with that much?
- [Woman] No that's I see.
You heard what I was talking about with,
I mean there's also say the way that Brian
would describe a perception
and it would be a little bit different.
So I'm trying to kind of
put this together with.
- Yeah, so this is very much from
the phenomenological perspective.
This is how, this is kind
of how perception seems.
It seems to attribute
these primitive qualities
to things in the world.
- [Woman] And then the point is again,
I find it very difficult
to try to talk about this
in a way that it's like,
I get into it a little bit
but then how to express it
in language is very hard.
So what do you mean?
What is acquaintance
here and what does it do?
- Yeah it's a good question.
I think the basic idea is we seem to stand
in a particular direct
epistemological relation
to these properties.
Both the properties in the
world, the redness out there.
I think phenomenologically it seems
that there's some redness out there
and it seems that I'm in
very direct contact with it.
I mean exactly what nature
that contact has is,
you know you can argue
about that but you know,
people have the catapult theories
and the intermission
theories and I don't know.
But also I think even more,
when it comes to consciousness itself
to my awareness of that
redness, my experience.
There's this idea that we have
some kind of direct acquaintance with,
with what it's like to be us.
Maybe more primitive than
any conceptual grasp.
It's just that those
properties are somehow
phenomenologically it feels like,
you know phenomenal properties
are just there for us.
When Mary sees red for the first time,
she becomes acquainted with
a certain kind of experience
that she hadn't had before.
And maybe that intuition is
wrong but I think it, it is a.
I don't know that it's a direct
phenomenological intuition.
I mean acquaintance is
kind of a technical term.
This is already getting
a little bit theoretical.
So think of it maybe more
as something which just lies behind
some of our more surface intuitions
as a potentially unifying
explainer of them,
this sense of acquaintance.
- Thank you.
- [Lori] Oh there's a, I see a question.
I will follow on the class here.
- [Woman] Yeah I know you yourself.
- Thanks.
- Hello.
I know you're not an illusionist yourself
but I kind of wanted to clarify that idea.
Normally with skepticism
there's kind of this gap
between what is and what we perceive.
So if I'm a skeptic, I
perceive a table here
but how I do know that
there actually is a table,
that there's nothing.
With illusionism,
how can there be a gap
between kind of what we think
we think and what we think.
To me, I'm kind of on
the, this is absurd camp
but I think there's probably
a more charitable explanation.
- Yeah, I mean certainly many people
have accused the view of
being somehow contradictory
or self undermining.
I think one way to put it is here.
That strong illusionism is contradictory
because you might think
that the illusion itself,
to undergo an illusion
is itself a kind of conscious experience.
So you're saying you're conscious.
Yeah, well you're not actually conscious.
You're merely,
you merely have the
illusion of consciousness.
Well if you understood that as requiring
the conscious experience
that you're conscious
then that would seem to be contradictory.
So I think the illusionist
had better understand illusions here
as something that doesn't
require consciousness.
I mean maybe it could be
something analogous to say
unconscious perception.
But maybe another way to think about it is
this is something that goes
on at the level of judgment.
We've got things we
perceive to be the case
and things we judge to
be the case and yeah,
maybe on views judgment is a conscious act
or very often a conscious act
but I think the thought is
we could, there is a version.
There's an analog of judgment,
the kind of mental act of
taking something to be the case
that needn't actually be conscious.
So maybe think of this as
a non-conscious judgment
that we are conscious.
Even maybe an AI system.
Think about an AI system that goes around
building these weird
representations of itself
as having these special properties.
No one's inclined to say
the AI system is conscious.
But it seems to at the very
least be producing the reports
that they're conscious.
I mean at the very least,
think of the judgment as
a disposition to report.
Then at least we've escaped
the charge hopefully
of contradiction.
Does that help?
- [Man] Thank you, just also
a purely clarifying question.
Can you say a little bit more
about what the coincidence is
that all realist and not
only epiphenomenalist
are meant to have to explain?
I didn't really understand
what the accusation is
from the illusionist side.
- Sorry, this was about
acquaintance specifically?
- [Man] Sorry, the coincidence.
- Coincidence, oh yeah you're right.
I didn't really say
nearly enough about that.
But I think, here's one idea.
Just say there's an
algorithmic explanation
of why we say the things
we say about consciousness
but there's no algorithmic
explanation of consciousness.
Consciousness is something
supra-algorithmic
as many realists think.
And then think that's at least
an uncomfortable explanation
'cause it starts to look
as if what our judgements
about consciousness
are made almost independently
of consciousness itself.
And if then you go on to say,
"Well but actually there are
"these properties of consciousness
"over and above the algorithm.
"And the algorithm is getting them right."
You know when it says,
"Yeah I'm having that red experience.
"I'm having experience that is structured
"in a certain way, that's all going on."
Then it starts to look like,
"Boy, it's really lucky
"that we actually got these things right."
'Cause it looks like well that
algorithm could've gone on
without consciousness.
It could've gone on with
different consciousness.
Maybe the psychophysical laws,
the laws connecting
algorithms and consciousness
are such that at least most of the time
that's gonna be right.
But even then it starts to look like,
"Boy lucky that we live in a world
"where the psychophysical laws
"connect up the algorithms
to consciousness that way."
So it's something like as a thought
and I don't intend it to be conclusive.
I think there are lots
of things to say in reply
and I've heard people say
interesting things in reply
but I did feel that's,
for me that's perhaps the most,
actually the most forceful
objection to realism
about consciousness.
- [Man] Hi, I noticed that
you said something about
how the problem reports
are kind of evidence.
Or it seemed like you were implying
that they're kind of evidence.
Not only that consciousness exists
but also that it has a tangible,
noticeable effect on the
world that we perceive
and I was wondering what
are your thoughts on like,
arguments about how
evolutionary function could,
like why would it be beneficial
for an organism to evolve
to not only present the
information that it experiences
to the conscious processes of the,
if consciousness is a physical process.
Why would it present it to
that in an organized way?
And then why would it
listen for a response
from the conscious process
and then allow that to affect the world
in an organized way?
- So what would be the
evolutionary benefit of?
- [Man] Like why would it be beneficial
for an organism to evolve so that it
not only responds to phenomena outside
but it also delivers it
to this mysterious
consciousness phenomenon
and then listens?
I'm not so much just asking this question,
I'm just asking like what do
you think of those arguments?
Do you think that they hold water?
Do you think they limit it in some way?
- I don't have any good story to tell
about the evolutionary benefits
of consciousness itself.
This is one of the deepest
mysteries in the field.
Anything you might posit we
need consciousness for that,
looks like in principle,
it's hard to see why you couldn't do that
without consciousness.
On the other hand,
where the meta-problem is concerned,
maybe there's something
interesting we can say
about why there are evolutionary benefits
in having a model of consciousness
that attributes these special properties
of consciousness to you.
I mean I think of this, just
start say with the color case.
Why might it be useful to have perceptual,
some kind of model of colors
as these primitive things
in the world?
Maybe in the model, and the model's got,
it doesn't build in these
complex reflective properties
that exist in reality.
Well we don't need all that complexity
just to make these distinctions.
It just turns out well it's really useful
to be able to you know, distinguish
certain kinds of fruits from others
and certain kinds of
physical objects from others
and these are attributing
these primitive qualities
is just a really good way to do that.
Likewise when it comes to,
I mean you can easily tell a story
about why it's useful
for us to have a model
of our own mind.
And have a model indeed
of other people's minds
and then at least with
a bit Of hand waving,
you can tell some story about why it might
actually be useful to say,
"Oh whenever we're."
Instead of saying we've got
these really complex causal,
representational relations
to things in the world.
It's like no, we have the
simple relation of consciousness
to those qualities.
Now I don't have a detailed
version of that story.
People like Graziano and Nick Humphrey
have tried to sketch versions
of stories like that.
I think there's at least
an interesting research program there
of looking at the benefits of self models
with certain properties
that may be for example,
socially useful in
dealing with other people.
You know we have to communicate
our states of mind with each other.
Having a kind of, yeah maybe
certain kinds of self models
involving models of
consciousness can help.
- [Woman] I was wondering
if you differentiate between
consciousness related and
consciousness independent sources
of problem intuitions.
I was reading the paper
that talked about that
and I was confused about
how any of these intuitions
that presumably come
from our conscious mind
could be truly independent
of consciousness.
- Yeah, I think what I
actually say in the paper
is I want them to be topic neutral.
I don't want these explanations
to mention consciousness anywhere.
If they mention consciousness,
then they're no longer gonna be neutral
between the illusionist and the realist.
But I do think it's true
that at least the realist
has got to look at some of
the things I say here and say,
"All those things are
consequences of consciousness."
Why do we have these introspective models
deploying introspective concepts?
Because we're conscious and you know,
we're acquainted with
consciousness and whatever.
And that's what actually
gives us the models
and the concepts.
Why do our models perceptually
attribute these qualities?
Because there really are these qualities,
at least In the mind.
We really acquainted with consciousness.
So I think that's a realist can say
that this topic-neutral explanation
is in fact dependent on consciousness.
On the other hand, the
illusionist I think can endorse,
hopefully endorse this
without saying any of it
is dependent on consciousness
and we somehow come to have
these introspective models.
Without consciousness we have
this sense of acquaintance.
Without consciousness but
somehow all that gives us
the sense that we're conscious.
So I guess yeah, the rule is.
I think the rule is not
that this has to be consciousness
independent in the sense
that it's not actually grounded
in conscious consciousness.
But maybe it's meant to
be at least an explanation
that one can grasp without,
without it somehow immediately entailing
or requiring the
existence of consciousness
if that makes sense.
But yeah there's probably
a few different notions
of conscious dependence here
that I could probably be more
careful about separating.
- [Man] I think we have
time for one more question
before David has to head
upstairs to the seminar.
Ian.
- [Ian] So I have a
question about emergentism.
In the study of complex systems,
for example neuroscience,
one of the common theme
is that you can never,
you can never explain the property
of complex collective systems
from the single constituents.
For example, memory and learning.
Those complex functions can only emerge
from the complex interaction
or dynamics between the groups.
So I will,
so I will ask do you think
the way Mary sees color
is one of those emergent properties
that cannot be explained by
the simple, simple materialism?
- Yeah, so I think it is fairly plausible
that consciousness emerges
from brain processes somehow
but I think this word
emergence kind of covers up
a variety of sins.
It's like sometimes I say it's a kind of,
like a magic word that people use
to make them feel better about
things they don't understand.
It's like the key question is
how does it emerge and why?
Philosophers sometimes
distinguish strong emergence
from weak emergence.
Strong emergence involves
something fundamentally new.
Weak emergence is more
like what you get say,
in nonlinear systems.
The game of life, it follows
a few very simple rules
at the bottom level.
And at the higher levels,
yeah some really surprising things happen.
But in those cases,
it looks like the surprising things,
they're surprising but
they're not too surprising
in the sense that if you
actually work through
the low level processes carefully
you can tell some pretty
straightforward story
about how it is that all
those rules come together
and they'll generate the
high level phenomena.
Say if I don't know,
life or behavior of
complex cellular entities.
So that's weak emergence.
And in those cases actually,
but what needed explaining was
still something much closer
to the easy problems.
Some complicated functional
things that a system does
and yeah surprisingly some
simple mechanisms can do that.
Nothing like that seems to
work I think for consciousness.
It doesn't seem to just be a matter of,
oh my God it's somewhat surprising
but in principle if you
work through it enough
you can see how this
would, this would come out.
I mean the gap seems of a
somewhat different character here.
It just seems like a
different kind of thing
you're trying to explain.
Not one of those objective
functions and because of that,
you know, the gap seems
to be much more principled
and this leads to it being a case
of what philosophers call
strong emergence and yeah,
if it's strong emergence
then the question is,
"Now with something fundamentally new
"maybe involving fundamentally
new properties in nature."
Now it starts to look like a version
of what philosophers
call property dualism.
Which I think is okay and
that's also a possibility
but insofar as many people
want to use emergence
to kind of support a materialist view,
come on it's just another
emergent property.
Like life or like the weather.
That will only work if
it's weak emergence, not.
If that's meant to support
a materialist production,
that will only work if
it's weak emergence.
But I think that's less plausible
in the case of consciousness.
- Okay everybody, we are
in an awkward position now
because we have already applauded
for these excellent ideas
that David just shared with us
and it would be sort of
weird to just do that again.
So let us go meta and applaud David
for handling the questions
and the organization
of these ideas into talk.
(audience applauds)
- I applaud your applause.